mais d'abord donc ce bras de fer pour la
présidence de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée entre d'un côté le
rassemblement national de l'autre la
nouvelle union politique écologique et
sociale civile de l'être
il aura fallu trois tours pour désigner
le président de la commission des
finances c'est finalement l'un sommet et
eric coquerel qui a été désigné avec
vingt-et-une voix contre 11 pour son
adversaire du rassemblement national et
9 pour la candidate des républicains
je précise que je suis élue de toute la
commission des finances un poste très
disputé car hautement stratégique la
commission contrôler les budgets mais
peut aussi mener des enquêtes fiscales
son président peut avoir accès aux
dossiers de particuliers comme
d'entreprise n'était pas de contrôler où
je fais je sais qu'elle peut faire
quelques chasses aux sorcières
personnel ou indivis donne par contre si
je peux me servir de lever des secrets
fiscaux pour que travailler avec la
commission sur les questions d'évasion
fiscale je ne m'en priverai pas une
élection scrutées par les sénateurs les
deux instances se retrouvent
régulièrement pour travailler en
commission mixte paritaire
peut-être il sortira sans doute de d'un
formatage qu'on a pu connaître dans le
passé là je crois qui aura une vraie un
vrai débat tel qu'il doit se mener qui
doit permettre finalement la commission
des finances et ne pas se contenter
peut-être d'une vision trop comment dire
trop proche du gouvernement le député de
seine-saint-denis siège déjà au sein de
la commission des finances depuis cinq
ans pas suffisant pour rassurer sur ses
capacités à mener les travaux c'est des
cons nature très très politique très
politicienne peut-être pas assez
technique pour en faire vraiment un gros
travail de liste à des saisies sur la
législation saisit pas d'être en tribune
pour faire valoir des idéologies premier
grand chantier à venir la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat et le projet de loi de
finances rectificative ils seront
examinés par le parlement à partir de la
mi juillet
eric coquerel à la présidence de la
commission d finances mais aussi la
composition du futur gouvernement et se
teste pour la première ministre
elisabeth bornes avec le discours de
politique générale le 5 juillet prochain
on parlera aussi dans ce premier débat
de sens public de l'avenir dlr et de la
succession de christian jacob bref c'est
riche et donc je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités christelle craplet
bonsoir bien si vous êtes directrice
générale adjointe de bva opinion
j'accueille également pascal perrineau
bonsoir politologue professeur à
sciences po paris albert et nous
rédacteur en chef du service politique
du figaro bonsoir bienvenue albert et
viti aqlpa éditorialiste politique
françois laetitia je commence avec vous
christelle rappeler que vous inspire
cette élection c'est une élection
d'eric coquerel je disais en titre
c'était un peu provocateur mais pas
seulement c'est vrai que le profil de
d'eric coquerel à ce poste là ça peut
surprendre oui effectivement après
c'était un petit peu attendu voilà au
regard de la composition de l'assemblée
on va voir ce que ça va donner quelle
attitude il va avoir et ce qu'il va être
plutôt dans la provocation justement où
est-ce qu'il va rentrer un peu dans le
jeu des institutions et puis surtout on
va voir un peu comment les français
réagissent à tout ça pour l'instant ils
observent sam un peu de loin il
construit le champ professionnel ça leur
échappe à priori une partie je pense que
voilà la même l'élection de d'eric
coquerel leur échappe en grande partie
mais quand même nous on a fait une
enquête ya pas très longtemps il
n'existait quand même plutôt une bonne
chose cette assemblée un peu inédite
voilà cette volonté un peu de discuter
d'avoir des forces d'opposition qu'on
n'avait pas forcément l'habitude de voir
en force comme ça ne représentait donc
voila c'était un champ qui s'ouvre est
ce intéressant albert et notion si on
dresse un peu le portrait d'eric
coquerel qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire au
delà des trois voies la d33 éléments que
je citais dans mes titres si on regarde
les anciens présidents de commission des
finances il est totalement atypique il
vient pas du sérail il n'a pas fait de
grandes études il n'a pas une il n'a pas
une expertise dans les comptes publics
dans en iran finances et là il son bac à
25 ans en candidat libre bon c'est ce ça
ne préjuge en rien de ses qualités
intellectuelles et morales mais en tous
cas c'est à dire qu'il ya eu moins armé
que quelqu'un qui a été ministre du
budget j'arrive dans sa carrière peu à
peu même à peu même beaucoup mais je
pense que après se sont passées de
trotski façon côté où sont présents
c'est on sait pas toujours si les
silices il est encore trop ce qu'ils
sont pas feints tous les cas il dit à de
l'extrême gauche et d'une extrême gauche
qui a fusionné avec un avec un islam au
gauchisme aussi donc on se rappelle que
lors de ces dernières élections
législatives il a il a agité très très
très fort les bleus drapeau du
communautarisme dans sa circonscription
dans son département la seine saint
denis est il du maire générale autour
d'eux autour d'eux les filles donc il y
avait il y à il y a une à un substrat
idéologique très très fort chez chery
coquerel après la démocratie lusage
parlementaire veut que que 2 que la
majorité d'intervenants pas de
réélection c'est comme ça au jeu
christian jacob l'a regretté amèrement
puisque si aussi la république en marche
la renaissance avait décidé par cible
aux hausses brutales peut-être que mal
logés ont été interdits l'annulaire
quant à d'hier aurait été élu mais en
tous les cas les usages parlementaires
depuis 2002 puis que la l'instauration
par nicolas sarkozy de la présidence de
la commission des finances offert à plat
à l'opposition et de ne pas participer
la majorité donc c'était comme ça
pourquoi ils n'ont pas participé enfin
celle usages c'est la tradition mais
pourquoi je vais suivre la tradition je
croyais que manuel macron était dans la
transgression et dans le dépassement
depuis longtemps voulu ils ont pas voulu
je crois que n'ont pas osé aller là où
on s'est posé la question il ya été ça a
été
ça a été en discussion pendant très
longtemps au sein de au sein de la
majorité pour voir comment éviter du
sens puisque il semblait inéluctable de
voir eric coquerel prendre la présence
de la commission donc
c'était l'une des solutions jeu
quasiment la seule parce que le à moins
qu'il y ait eu un accord entre le rn et
l air et là c'est encore une autre paire
de manches pascal perrineau on peut
comprendre que renaissance et pas voulu
rentrer dans le rang dans ce jeu là ou
pas forcément on peut peut-être pour pas
apparaître comme justement en rupture
avec une jeune tradition d'accord
laetitia remis comme lady albert zeh
nous en effet ils ont pensé à un autre
scénario mais n'ont pas osé ils n'ont
pas osé afin de ne pas donner
l'impression en effet d'être ce qu'ils
affrontaient un groupe dont on sait
qu'il va être purs blanc dont on sait il
a été turbulents mais maintenant il a la
main sur bull en a 17 voilà dix-sept
donc là ils vont être vraiment turbulent
est-ce que la turbulence atteindra le
coeur de la commission c'est un peu tôt
un peu tôt pour le dire mais on parle d'
usage et c'est vrai que l' usage 1 sec
la majorité n'interviennent pas mais il
y avait un autre usage c'est que le
poste devait aller au groupe le plus
important donc de l'opposition
donc ce week end donc ça aurait dû être
le rennais d'ici
là bien de là bien dès aujourd'hui
marc fesneau mais bien sûr marc fesneau
de l'adie si on considère le texte en
effet n'allait pas jusque là le
règlement intérieur mais lusage si on
croit que les pratiques politiques ce
sont deux choses c'est le respect des
textes et le respect de ce que les
anglais au fonds appelle la coutume 1
c'est-à-dire lusage si c'était le cas ça
devait aller au rassemblement national
donc voyez il ya une utilisation un peu
de poids deux mesures c'est un peu
sélectif la référence aux usages c'est
surtout qu'on ne comprend pas ce que ça
aurait déclenché si il avait participé
au vote s'il décide de ne pas respecter
ils l'expliquent enfin je ne pense pas
que la révolution aurait eu lieu le
lendemain non mais très honnêtement on
est un peu un peu très très loin des
radars des mets français mais le laury's
de tripatouillage
qu'ils auraient pu apparaître comme ne
voulant pas écouté la voix du peuple
alors c'est vrai que d'un autre côté ça
aurait pu revenir aux airelles mais la
nuit ps aurait probablement dit que
voilà c'était encore un arrangement la
marche qui à l'extrême droite comme il
le ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs du reste
dans leur discours ces derniers temps et
d'un point de vue en termes d'image il
aurait pu apparaître comme justement
faisant le marchepied ne respectant pas
les instructions essayons de tri fins de
faire un peu des manips et vu que les
politiques ont quand même une très
mauvaise image vu que la majorité quand
même en situation un peu délicate voilà
ça aurait pu être un plus si vous
permettez je crois qu'il ya encore une
fois on constate que dans la vie
politique française il ya deux poids
deux mesures
l'antifascisme
mobilise plus que l'anti extrémismes de
gauche voilà ça continue à marcher un
peu comme ça et la candidature coquerel
qui trouve une issue c'est ça hein parce
que au fond plusieurs ont préféré voilà
avoir donné cela sent le désir et bien
sûr à
un homme issu véritablement de l'extrême
gauche plutôt qu'un homme issu de
l'extrême droite du rassemblement
national qui était d'ailleurs pas lui un
vieux militant d'extrême droite c'est un
jeune voilà ça fait partie de la jeune
génération du rassemblement national
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien qu'en
france la culpabilité par rapport à ce
que l'on perçoit comme étant le fascisme
ça fonctionne encore tout même très bien
je trouve que c'est justement un des
points les plus intéressants de cette
séquence électorale c'est de redéfinir
ce qu'est l'extrême gauche redéfinir ce
qu'est la france insoumise redéfinir la
position des partis gouvernement de la
majorité vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite
et que ce soit un débat public un débat
de société par uniquement les politiques
qui ne le font pas vous allez remarquer
qu emmanuel macron les met dans un même
sac mais ne qualifie ni l'un ni l'autre
en disant ce n'est pas pareil mais quand
même et je crois qu'il serait sain pour
tous puisque maintenant ils sont
représentés de façon massive à
l'assemblée nationale d'en discuter
calmement parce que sinon on va créer
des halles du
calme non parce que effectivement albert
et nous je suis pas sûr que l'on puisse
avoir beaucoup de débats sereins à
l'assemblée avec deux blocs alors moi je
vais dire à radicaux pour ne fâcher
personne aux deux extrémités
je penserai compliqué même si on sent
que du côté du rassemblement national de
marine le pen il ya une volonté de
légitimation d'un site owni
d'institutionnalisation et donc de
vouloir jouer le jeu des institutions
doullens jeu le jeu parlementaire
on a bien vu que à partir au deuxième
tour pour l'élection de
privé elle s'est retirée pour laisser
alors qu'il n'y avait pas de n'y a pas
de doute sur les secondes élections donc
et on voit bien que il essaye de jouer
un rôle plutôt à s'agit plutôt
constructif entre guillemets si c'est le
mot à la mode et c'est de montrer que
ils peuvent être autre chose que que dès
que ddd des extrémistes qui viendraient
attisé les violences à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle pour le pour ce qui est de
la du ps mais on va dire les allées
fille puisque les socialistes et les
communistes sont d'habitude une
tradition parlementaire en ce très
ancien pour la peau et les fit
l'association et de la différente ils
ont une volonté de de s'exprimer et de
et 2 et 2 et de casser un peu le système
donc on va voir comment comment vont-ils
réagir tout au long de cette année de ce
mandat de soins dentaires je pense que
c'est c'est là où ça va ça va plus se
tirer est ce qu on a tous un peu
réinterpréter les résultats du 19 juin
certains disant c'est la fracture c3
france les autres en lisant les français
vous veulent que les partis politiques
négocié comme si voilà il y avait une
sorte d'intelligence collective moi je
peux y croire d'ailleurs de temps en
temps à l'intelligence collective alors
maintenant on a des sondages pour dire
vous m'avez dit sont satisfaits de cette
chambre ils veulent que les partis
négocient caisse et ckoi plus de retour
face à cette composition de l'assemblée
nationale ont cité un peu les nombres le
nombre de députés de chaque partie pour
que l'elysée parce qu'il y en a plein
quand même ils savaient pas forcément il
nous disait quand même majoritairement
c'est une bonne chose ça va permettre
aux gens de discuter ça va renforcer le
rôle du parlement ils ne voulaient
clairement pas que mme emmanuelle macro
et un peu les pleins pouvoirs donc après
derrière chacun y voit un peu midi à sa
porte chacun se dit ça va aller dans mon
sens les sympathisants et les filles
sont ravies se disent va y avoir la
gauche qui va être plus fort pareil pour
les sympathisants du rassemblement
national pas sûr que voilà on arrive
vraiment à des vraies discussions mais
en tout cas la perception était plutôt
positive alors vous allez y avec un
quart qui nous disaient qu'ils avaient
un risque de paralysie alors on va voir
maintenant avec jonathan du prix est ce
qu'il va être juste là évidemment
derrière le rideau bon soir jonathan
bienvenue ont fait le point sur le
calendrier parlementaire des prochaines
semaines lui qui voulait prendre des
vacances vont devoir attendre un peu
mais c'est raté un essai le calendrier
s'annonce chargé voire très très chargé
on peut lire un thomas après quatre mois
de pause les députés les sénateurs et
bien ils vont retrouver leur hémicycle
respectif le décret de convocation du
parlement en session extraordinaire
il a été publié hier au journal officiel
et les assembler ce matin même ont réuni
leur conférence des présidents pour
déterminer très précisément leur
calendrier à venir donc là vous allez
voir l'un des temps forts un début
juillet eh bien ça va être en fait les
deux déclarations devant l'assemblée
nationale et du et du sénat d'elisabeth
bornes ce sera le 6 juillet prochain au
palais bourbon et pour le moment on sait
pas si la locataire de matignon elle va
engager sa responsabilité ou non devant
les députés et le soir elle viendra au
sénat ensuite à 21h où ce sera le même
jour le 6 juillet et il ya une série de
textes importants qui vont être examinée
ensuite ouais ça va commencer par un
projet de loi contenant diverses mesures
sur le co vie de 19 encore des bateaux
et sans doute examiné en séance publique
le 11 juillet à l'assemblée le 20 au
sénat si logiquement tout avance à un
rythme on va dire normal à l'assemblée
mais tous les amateurs de joutes
politiques et vont probablement attendre
le 18 juillet avec le projet de loi sur
la protection du pouvoir d'achat qui
risque un de ferraille est un peu un il
contient des mesures destinées à
atténuer notamment le choc de
l'inflation notamment une hausse des
prestations sociales pourquoi pas aussi
la prolongation du bouclier tarifaire
des prix de l'énergie ou encore la rva
lire la revalorisation de 3 5% du
salaire des fonctionnaires
donc ça y restent y avoir débat est donc
conséquences de ce texte sur le budget
voté l'hiver dernier et bien en fait il
va y avoir un projet de loi de finances
rectificative et ça ce sera le 20
juillet à l'assemblée nationale est ici
côté senna est ce que c'est un peu plus
flou je crois oui c'est un peu plus flou
parce que hormis les questions
d'actualité qui sont gravées dans le
marbre on peut le dire il ya quelques
textes européens aussi à transposer ici
ou des conventions internationales
ratifiées mais en fait le sénat il va
être tributaire des échanges de
l'assemblée nationale pour récupérer les
textes et donc s'il ya gros blocage
politique ce qui pourrait arriver eh
bien les sénateurs il pourrait récupérer
les textes très très tardivement et voir
leurs sessions s'éternise et pourquoi
pas jusqu'à la mi août donc ça ça fait
sourire le président des centristes
hervé marseille tu d'ailleurs
officiellement le calendrier s'arrête le
7 août mais sous réserve de la longueur
des débats à l'assemblée nationale il ya
un certain nombre de groupes qu'on peut
qualifier peut-être de turbulents qui
peuvent allonger les débats et les
délais donc la page blanche on attend de
voir comment vont se comporter les uns
et les autres et nous nous y sommes
prêts
j'espère
que c'est dans cet état d'esprit que
nous pourrons travailler voilà un peu de
malice un volant temps d'aimer un
message constructif des députés oui bah
oui bien pouvoir et on les comprend
prendre quelques vacances merci jonathan
de tous ces détails et moi j'aimerais
qu'on se s'arrête les uns et les autres
sur cette date du mardi 5 juillet date
entouré de rouge dans l'agenda
d'elisabeth bornes cette pression là un
peu majeur sur un seul discours en
préparant les missions ça m'a fait
penser au meeting de valérie pécresse au
zénith à paris un extrait
cette épreuve a réveillé nos aspirations
profondes celles d'une vie plus libre
plus douce une vie plus proche des siens
plus proche de la nature
ses attentes ses désirs il faut aussi
répondre
je veux porter un nouvel espoir celui
d'une nouvelle france que nous devons
reconstruire ensemble
voilà mauvais souvenir évidemment pour
valérie pécresse albert et nous est-ce
que elisabeth bornes joue aussi gros
mardi prochain le 5 juillet ou pas
forcément elle joue gros même très gros
peut-être pas aussi gros que pour les
pécresse puisqu'elle a été confortée
d'une certaine manière donc le poids de
la responsabilité s'est un peu atténuée
emmanuel macron la renouveler sa
confiance donc elle sait qu'elle est là
pour quelques temps tous les cas donc la
pression est peut-être un peu moindre
mais une chose est sûre c'est que ce
discours va être un des deux fondateurs
il s'agit de dalé d'aller trouver une
nouvelle majorité d'aller chercher
auprès des groupes d'opposition bain des
failles des fêlures des soutiens
d abstention positive
il ya plein de choses à faire donc il y
a
il faudra que ce discours soit soit soit
la mort de quelque chose qui à quelques
elle qu'elle arrive à donner envie alors
ça n'est pas une grande oratrice on l'a
tous ceux constatés
il s'agit que sont le fonds en tous les
cas soient là la forme laissera
peut-être pas mais bon après tout c'est
pas non plus le rôle du premier ministre
d'être seulement un grand orateur même
si ça c'est quelque chose vous savez
tout le monde m'attend au tournant signé
donc il s'agira s'agit pour elle de
surtout pas rater cette 7,7 cet exercice
qui était formel mais il faut encore
faut-il la logique d'autant qu'on ne
sait pas s'il y aura une question sur la
question de confiance sera le vote de
confiance sera réclamée au point
évidemment je crois j'ai dit mardi 5
juillet c'est bien le 6 1 6 2
ce serait le cinquième essai pour ça
j'étais resté sur la sur l'ancienne date
merci vous êtes supposé vraiment sympa
albert et christelle rabelais c'est le
sait le bruit médiatique finalement
autour de deux discours de politique
générale qui viendra aux oreilles des
français assez peu vont le regarder même
sera diffusé sur les chaînes
parlementaires mais c'est nos
commentaires c'est le bruit médiatique
lundi après effectivement alors pour
l'instant moi je trouve qu'elle résiste
pas trop mal elisabeth bornes dans notre
dernière enquête à la 41 % de bonnes
opinions alors évidemment c'est beaucoup
moins que le mois d'avant l'a testé pour
la première fois mais pour l'instant il
n'est pas encore très identifiée du coup
elle prend un peu moins de coups c'est
quand même emmanuel macron qui concentre
toutes les critiques et au moment des
législatives c'est quand même lui voilà
sur lesquels les français sont montés
les plus critiques à voir si ça va durer
jusqu'à présent si on surmonte un peu
dans le temps on a le précédent premier
ministre jean castex qui suivait un peu
emmanuel macron en termes de popularité
on va voir elle où elle se situe pour
l'instant c'est un petit peu mieux donc
à suivre pascal perrineau sion fait un
peu d'histoire il ya des discours de
politique générale comme ça qu'ils ont
un peu emporté en flammes et le
parlement bien sûr moi de mes premiers
souvenirs c'était jacques chaban delmas
le discours sur la nouvelle société ça
n'était pas un grand orateur de meetings
jacques chaban delmas mais il avait fait
un discours dans lequel le fonds était
tellement audacieux d'ailleurs trop
audacieux pour le président pompidou qui
avait une dimension davantage
conservatrice que quelques mois plus
tard georges pompidou ce sens né s'en
est séparé oui il ya de grands discours
qui sont délivrés à l'occasion de
déclaration de politique générale il
s'agit d'abord de mobiliser sa majorité
ça c'est très importante même ah
parceque ils ont une majorité
relativement encore faut-il que la
majorité relative se disent voilà on est
pleinement représentée par cette
nouvelle première ministre et puis
ensuite il faut en effet des signes
d'ouverture comme le disait albert et
nous tout à l'heure des signes
d'ouverture faire regarder tout même il
ya je crois 9 non-inscrits il ya un
groupe qui s'est créée à la charnière
j'allais dire de la gauche pour
l'instant unis combien de temps ça va
durer et de la macro ni inquiet qui est
là avec des u10 des divers gauche des
divers droite il faut aussi qu'elle
parle des ultramarins extrêmement
important il faudra mais c'est presque
une convention mais il faudra que la
france d'outre-mer la france ultramarine
soit présente dans le discours de la
première ministre donc quel voilà
qu'elle tente non pas d'arriver à une
impossible majorité absolue mais quelque
chose de plus confortable que la
majorité relative un peu mince à
laquelle
dont lé chef pour l'instant enfin le
chef des chefs bordeaux 2 enfin g
d'emmanuel mâcon en deux
pendant x non je disais peut-être qu'on
aura enfin le programme des manuels ma
compassion pour la santé va donc c'est
ça aussi qui est attendu mais moi je
suis persuadé c'est pas la première fois
que je le dis sur ce plateau que
lisabeth bornes elle a déjà fait la
preuve de sa pugnacité dans d'autres
dans d'autres circonstances où quand
elle était ministre dans des
circonstances quand elle était
présidente de la ratp ou quand il était
ministre et elle peut vraiment nous
surprendre dans les jours qui viennent
d'autant que contrairement à 2017 sais
pas si vous vous rappelez mais juste
avant le discours de police générale de
d'edouard philippe le président de la
république avait fait avec une
intervention devant le parlement il
avait fait son discours de politique
générale la veille ou l'avant-veille de
discours de des doigts fils et à une
mauvaise manière faite au premier
ministre puisque que dire après le
président de la république deux jours
après après son intervention devant le
parlement c'est donc là je pense que les
habitants de n'aura pas ce ce poids ce
poids supplémentaire de la concurrence
présidentielle je voudrais qu'on vienne
sur un autre élément évoqué par jonathan
du président dans sa liste là des textes
importants à venir au parlement sur le
pouvoir d'achat avec ce pavé dans la
mare lancé par michel edouard leclerc
aujourd'hui qui dénonce les profiteurs
de l'inflation ce qui m'intéresse pascal
perrineau c'est qu'ils demandent une
commission d enquête parlementaire il ya
là alors c'est pas la première fois mais
on peut se dire qu'on est dans le dans
ce moment aussi où le parlement reprend
nuire par la force dans notre histoire
politique et si celle ci attire les
français qui fait qu'aujourd'hui en
effet jeudi sous fond tout ça c'est pas
mal parce qu'il découvre l'aspect
contrepoids le jour où contrepoids j'ai
une force de blocage là ils apprécieront
certainement beaucoup moins mais pour
l'instant en effet les françaises
sentait depuis des zones et même bien
avant l'actuel président que le système
siper présidentialiser de manière
excessive un tout le monde de gauche de
droite est d'ailleurs là un coup d'arrêt
a été donné c'est vrai un coup d'arrêt
donné et on voit que le lieu politique
regarder toutes les émissions tout ce
dont on parle et c'est c'est ce qui se
passe au parlement mais c'est la
première fois depuis mai extrêmement
longtemps qu'elle n'a créé par allal
puis presque huit jours voilà bien sûr
mais voilà il
regardez même pendant la campagne comme
il avait choisi cette fameuse stratégie
du silence il s'est auto exclu avant de
partir lui même bon mais va revenir il
va revenir voilà mais en effet on a un
président qui d'abord ne sais pas
comment prendre cette affaire parce
qu'au fond lui c'était moule est
complètement dans l'hyperprésidence
et comment fait-on avec une république
est en train de ce parlement arisée une
cinquième république qui sépare le
mentalisme on savait très bien dans la
cohabitation les trois cohabitations que
l'on a connu comment on faisait avec une
république parlementaire on avait une
lecture comme on dit primo ministériel
c'était le premier ministre et la
majorité au parlement mais là on est
dans encore dans autre chose on est dans
une république dans lequel le président
une majorité relative mais c'est
insuffisant et donc le lui le lieu du
débat politique se déplace au parlement
que fait le président comment
trouve-t-il sa place dans ce nouvel
espace ça n'est pas ça j'aimerais pas
être à sa place ça n'est pas simple mais
c'est ce à quoi on assiste mais c'est
très intéressant parce que pour
l'instant il ya un aspect laboratoire on
va avoir sur la loi sur la coved et la
résurgence de l'aco vibrons ça c'est
important non le verra surtout sur la
loi du du sur le pouvoir d'achat là où
voir on va voir véritablement si on va
vers un contrepoids parlementaire ou si
l'on va vers le blocage est évidemment
comme celle attentes principales des
français les oppositions alors le
gouvernement et non mais les oppositions
seront également jugés sur leur
souplesse ou leur capacité à participer
à oui tout à fait et je vous rejoins
totalement sur le fait qu'il n'aime pas
le blocage est du reste de quand on
faisait des enquêtes s'il est parfois on
disait l'exécutif est mal perçu il ya
beaucoup de critiques mais n'y avait pas
tellement de personnes en face qui
trouvé grâce aux yeux des français ils
sont aussi très critique à l'égard de
l'opposition ils sont très critiques à
l'égard de jean luc mélenchon dont la
personnalité est restée extrêmement
clivante
effectivement les oppositions nous ont
aussi à jouer pour gagner en crédibilité
montré que bah si elles sont pas
d'accord quelle alternative comment elle
se positionne ça c'est un vrai enjeu
pour les uns dernier mot ensuite on
parle d'un remaniement voit sur le
pouvoir d'achat la capacité d opposition
a créé le mouvement et à proposer
quelque chose le texte du gouvernement
va être discutée mais chaque chaque
groupe chaque parti a des idées bien
arrêtées on sait que le rassemblement
national veut le jouer sur la tva la
majorité plutôt sur des chèques déchets
avec l'inflation la droite veut que les
comptes publics soient respectés et que
rondot dont qu'on ne fasse pas exposer
la dette donc chacun va vouloir
peut-être voter ou pas s'abstenir pas et
mais si en contrepartie on obtient
quelque chose il va falloir que la
majorité accepte aussi le rôle des
oppositions et donc de propositions d
opposition ça vous intéresse mais c'est
ce que disait le pré nationale gérard
larcher on a diffusé son intervention il
ya deux jours soit dans cette émission
et disait
le gouvernement l'exécutif doit
apprendre à travailler différemment nous
aussi il y avait voilà c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'on a déjà dit ici mais on a tous
été quand même habitué libre au nez à la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée il faut
qu'on change un peu nos logiciels
respectifs alors on va parler du du
remaniement maintenant
et d'abord du cac damien abad une
enquête ouverte après le dépôt d'une
plainte de nom d'une élue centriste
compte remise et solidarité pour des
faits remontant à 2011 questions simples
laëtitia est ce que damien abad peut
rester au gouvernement pour le moment
les seules informations dont nous
disposons je pense que albert confirmera
parviennent des coulisses du monde
politique et on comprend qu'ils aient
pas de borne a bien envie de s'en
séparer de se séparer du ministre des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées mais il n'y a pas
de déclaration officielle alors
elisabeth bornes et d'amea bat ça ne
marche pas thomas déjà elle a très mal
pris que finalement son arrivée à
matignon soit parasité par la sphère
damien abad elle l'a reçu et il a
demandé en tête à tête des réponses
claires sur des questions directes et
elle n'était pas du tout satisfaite de
ce rendez vous et surtout rappelez vous
après dans la foulée des révélations de
médiapart elle avait dit face caméra
lors d'un déplacement dans le calvados
que elle prendrait des décisions qu'elle
tirerait les conséquences si la justice
se saisisse et de la faire donc c'est
pour ces raisons et dans ce contexte
évidemment qui hier l'opposition a une
nouvelle fois fait entendre sa voix
certaines voix de l'opposition comme
celle de sandrine rousseau l'écologiste
cendres et non sa démission démission
elisabeth mende disait que si une
enquête était ouverte il sortirait du
gouvernement une enquête est ouverte il
doit sortir du gouvernement 7 il y avait
la possibilité de le mettre à pied
temporairement ça n'a pas été fait
maintenant il faut démissionner vous le
disiez laetitia des des voix se sont
déjà élevées pour demander la démission
dahlab de damien abad sans succès
emmanuel macron tout cas pour l'instant
semble vouloir le maintenir oui la
protéger au départ mais maintenant il ya
un remaniement thomas donc s'ils ont des
plug on se sépare de damien abad ça
passera certainement plus inaperçu et
encore une fois si cela ne tenait qu'à
elisabeth bornes il serait déjà sortis
juste petite parenthèse dans cet édito
pour vous dire qu elisabeth bande a
quand même de la personnalité car elle a
tenu tête à emmanuel macron elle voulait
que abad sorte emmanuel macron a dit non
je le maintiens pourquoi parce qu'il ne
voulait pas faire de damien abad à un
précédent politique c'est à dire qu'il
veut ni céder à la pression médiatique
ni de l'opinion publique rappelez vous
lors d'un déplacement plusieurs
d'ailleurs le chef de l'état était pris
à partie en demandant certains français
ont demandé la démission de la minuad il
a tenu bon mais quand même il semblerait
et ça c'est vraiment le bruit albert
vous me direz si vous avez le même qui
est majeur là en ce moment c'est que
matignon va se séparer de damien abad et
lui il le sait est donc pour le moment
ils essayent de convaincre en fait ses
pairs de son utilité et son utilité
c'est qu'il a dirigé le groupe ait l'air
à l'assemblée nationale et que donc dans
cette assemblée disparates il pourrait
être utile pour l'instant il préfère se
défendre à l'abri des médias oui il a
réussi pour l'instant il parle en off
aux journalistes alors on lit ici ou là
dans les journaux que il porte plainte
qui se défend qu'il que lui-même dément
toutes les accusations et qu' il est
combatif et puis il a hésité finalement
il a dit non je ne ferai pas de prise de
parole médiatique peut-être qu'il en a
parlé à emmanuel macron il n'est pas
proche des manuels macro elle ne fait
pas du tout partie de ses proches il ne
l'a pas vu en tête à tête et donc c'est
peut-être certainement les derniers
jours de damien abad selon libération je
ne sais pas selon le figaro met à
nouveau gouvernement pour être annoncés
dimanche ou lundi albert gêne ou
[Rires]
plusieurs fois dans son papier dans son
édito voilà est-ce que alors évidemment
on va pas jouer au petit jeu des
pronostics
il ya une affaire qui est
potentiellement grave encore une fois
présomption d'innocence on va on va
rester prudent mais si on est simplement
dans l'analyse politique c'est vrai
qu'il ya une fenêtre d'opportunité on
peut appeler ça comme ça quoi oui parce
que les joues les jeux de damien abad
sont peut-être pas compté mais en tous
les cas ils sont
grises une lettre d'autant que damien
abad n'apporte plus le la et plus tu
n'es plus porteur de quelque chose pour
le pour la pour le président de la
république et pour hervé le borgne il a
été il a été c'était une prise de guerre
au départ puisque président du groupe et
l'air on vient le chercher et on veut
casser à la fois la droite républicaine
et si possible trouver des alliances
avec d'autres députés aujourd'hui son
intérêt
politique et c'est très très très très
affaiblie c'est devenu dans cette poule
est kahn at oui d'autant que et parmi
les députés verts qui restent et n'est
pas en odeur de sainteté puisqu'il est
accusé de trahison de fidélité bon je
vous passe les détails oui et donc
effectivement je pense que mais la seule
le président isabelle bonne le savent
je pense qu'il a peu de chances d'être
reconduit après le remaniement ouais
crayssac craplet l'impact de cette
affaire sur l'opinion publique vous
l'avait évalué non l'a pas vraiment
évaluer c'est compliqué à évaluer mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'on parle de damien abad aujourd'hui
on fait référence à la faire que ce soit
dans les médias que et ça en terme
d'image comme c'est pas quelqu'un de
très connu de 13 identifié qui aux yeux
des français avaient un poids très
important
bah mine de rien il ya quand même un peu
une association ça devient un peu
compliqué je pense de le garder et puis
après ce qui est compliqué aussi en
terme d'image c'est quand même que
manuel macron a souvent été attaqué sur
ses insuffisances sur la grande cause de
l'égalité hommes-femmes de la prise en
compte de tous ces sujets là ça vient en
rajouter encore pour montrer que
peut-être pour certains il ne prendrait
pas assez ce sujet à bras le corps ça
devient un peu handicap sont
effectivement ce que vous disiez qui est
à côté de gros atouts qui viennent le
compenser au-delà du cas abad pascal
perrineau les enjeux de ce remaniement
finalement bon il n'y a pas d'accord de
gouvernement il n'y a pas de coalition
là ça aurait pu être long on l'aurait
évalués au chausse-pied presque le
gouvernement dans ce cas là là qu'est ce
qui peut se passer un ou deux débauchage
oui il peut y avoir un ou deux des baux
charge parce que bon peut-être pas ça
sera pas la prise de guerre qu'ils
étaient tous même damien pas au début
mais on peut imaginer il y a plusieurs
lr macron compatibles donc pourquoi pas
continuer dans cette tradition on en
connaît plusieurs bon
ça c'est la première chose afin de
montrer qu'il y a tout même un
pluralisme politique il ne faut pas que
dans une période il va falloir négocier
sans cesse on ait l'impression d'un
gouvernement qui se replient entièrement
sur la macro ni il faut que ce soit un
gouvernement qui s'ouvre un gouvernement
d'ouverture pas avec bien sûr un groupe
d'opposition tant que tel mais un
gouvernement d'ouverture dans les hommes
et les femmes qui le composent il faut
aussi que ses ministres et des capacités
à négocier
on s'est parfois il ya des bons
ministres mais qui sont un peu raides du
collier qui voit là
eux savent pas négocier un c'est pas
vraiment leur culture là je crois qu'on
aura intérêt à avoir des hommes et les
femmes qui savent véritablement négocier
sur les projets de loi qui aille voir
les députés comme le faisait d'ailleurs
quand il était ministre de l'économie et
des finances emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron était un homme extrêmement actif
dans le parlement pour essayer de voilà
d'avoir des majorités plus large que
celle de son camp qui était la gauche
donc il faut ce type de tempérament
simplement ce type de tempérament est
assez rare donc on va les comptes et au
futur gouvernement un jour un dernier
chapitre dans ce dans ce débat consacré
à l'avenir du parti et l'air et la
succession de christian jacob il quitte
la présidence comme prévu il a un
successeur en tête
je vais arrêter là tous des dents dans
quelques jours ensuite notre processus
électoral fait que les élections ont
lieu en octobre ou début début novembre
j'ai toujours considéré que le laurent
wauquiez avait tout toutes les qualités
pour
pour reprendre la présidence du parti
maintenant c'est un choix d'abord à
choix personnel pour lui ce qu'il est
candidat ou pas ensuite ce sera le choix
de nos de nos militants albert inouk a
dit en wolof laurent wauquiez vous il a
déjà été président il a su attirer
avec avec une sortie un peu un peu
bizarre enfin on se rappelle qu'il avait
de l'eau pas obligé de démissionner
après les élections européennes qui
avaient vu le parti décembre avec
isabella mis en tête de liste a produit
pour cent des voix donc invités à une
contre-performance
leur voquer je pense qu'il a en tête de
prendre le parti le problème c'est le
timing c'est est ce que c'est maintenant
est ce que c est ce que c'est juste
avant les élections européennes après
les élections européennes 2024 la course
à 2027 est déjà dense est déjà lancé et
tout et tout et tout et qui sont amies
jeu vraisemblablement ce sera lui le
président le prochain face le président
dvd les remix quand c'est tout tu l'as
dit qu'il aille de la question c'est
quand est ce qu'il est ce qu'il a
vraiment envie d'aller plus de prendre
tout de suite le parti pour y faire quoi
pour relancer quoi s'est il ya de vraies
interrogations d'autant que il a uni
dans une position
plutôt confortable il a été élu
confortablement à la tête de la grande
région auvergne rhône-alpes il a il a un
budget
conséquent il fait des choses il a la
capacité la possibilité de montrer qu'il
fait des choses et qu'il ait réussi des
choses
avec d'ailleurs avec l'ensemble une
majorité beaucoup plus large que celle
induite holler donc ils travaillent ils
travaillent avec le modem par exemple
donc il ya aussi cette volonté de
montrer qu'il est qu'il est qu'il est
ouvert a pas seulement à une partie une
partie de cet électorat de droite plutôt
plutôt conservateur mais je pense qu'il
y là il a une envie après ces questions
d'opportunité timing ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on l'a pas beaucoup
entendu ces derniers mois et il est
sorti du bois par exemple sur l' affaire
du burkini
de façon vraiment pour le coup au raid
radical voilà il a dit ce qu'il en
pensait il a même menacé de couper des
financements à eric piolle maire de
grenoble donc on vous comprend quand
même le positionnement qu'il va adopter
uniquement avec cette sortie je ne dis
pas que ça peut faire toute une
politique pour un groupe mais bon
laurent wauquiez c'est l'une des grandes
figures qui installèrent allez on parle
souvent du manque de manque de banc
comme on dit au football donc il ya des
personnalités ne sont pas si nombreuses
que ça et il en reste une une principale
seller évoqué il ya toujours la figure
de france à darois mais sait pas trop
s'il veut revenir enfin visiblement non
mais j'ai toujours mais il est il et il
est celui qui incarne quelque chose le
chef et il y là il a une ossature et une
nature idéologique une colonne
vertébrale il est de droite et il est
aujourd'hui pour les l'air c'est
important d'être de droite et de
respecter cette cette appartenance à
cette famille la politique c'est au
gaullisme à une forme d'autorité de
l'état qui est parfois malmenée donc il
reste il reste sept cette figure un peu
importante pour les leurs pour l'instant
on va terminer là dessus creissels
rappelé effectivement si ça reste
dans l'opinion il et il est bien
identifié laurent et c'est une
personnalité même identifié mais après
ce qui est important c'est qu'il parle
aux sympathisants lr anglet et permet
aux lycées interne c'est ce qu'il faut
et puis émincez les militants mes
oreilles plus largement qui s'adresse
aux gens sur qui nous lisent encore
aujourd'hui se sentir proche de l air et
qui n'ont pas basculé vers finalement
une sorte d'appréciation des manuels
macron et voilà c'est à ce coeur de
cible là qui doit parler effectivement
il a le on va dire le substrat
idéologique qui leur parle et qui peut
potentiellement du coup faire effet
merci beaucoup merci tous les toits
d'avoir participé à ce débat